اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار الملفات
السعوديه والخليج الى العناوين
[موسيقى]
روسيا تستعد لمضاعفه انتاج الصواريخ عاليه
الدقه وتؤكد ان اهدافها لن تتحقق في
اوكرانيا الا بالقوه
بعد انهيار سيليكون فالي الاسهم الماليه
العالميه تفقد نصفه ترليون دولار خلال
ثلاثه ايام
مع قرب شهر رمضان مكه تضاعف الفرق
الرقابيه وتسجل دخول سبعه ملايين معتمر من
خارج السعوديه
في الرابعه كذلك
لاول مره في السعوديه البدء بتجربه تقنيه
جديده لتبريد الطرق وتهدف لتخفيف حراره
الاحياء السكنيه
روشون تطلق اول مشاريعها في المنطقه
الشرقيه الفلوه سيوفر في مدينه الهفوف
اكثر من
18,000 وحده سكنيه
حياكم الله في حرب اوكرانيا اعتبرت روسيا
انها لن تحقق اهدافها سوى بالقوه تحذير
ياتي بالتزامن مع قرار امر به وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجيو بمضاعفه انتاج الاسلحه
التكتيكيه عاليه الدقه جاء ذلك خلال زياره
شويغو الى شركه الاسلحه الصاروخيه
التكتيكيه حيث تمت الاشاره الى نقل الى
نقل احدث العينات الى الاختبار قبل بدء
الانتاج
صنف برلمان دوله ليتوانيا الواقعه في شمال
اوروبا والحدوديه مع بيلاروسيا صنف مجموعه
باجنر العسكريه الروسيه على انها منظمه
ارهابيه كما تعمل برلمان الليتواني قوات
فاغنر بارتكاب جرائم عدوانيه ممنهجه
وخطيره في اوكرانيا
اعلنا رئيس الوزراء البولندي ماتيوز
مراوسكي ان بلاده تعتزم تزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات من طراز
وقال مراوسكي خلال مؤتمر صحفي ردا على
سؤال عن موعد تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه
المقاتلات اوضح انه قد يحدث ذلك خلال
الاربع او السته اسابيع المقبله
وزير الخارجيه الروسي الولايات المتحده
واستراليا وبريطانيا بتدبير مواجهه تستمر
لسنوات في اسيا عبر اطلاقها تحالف اكوس
بشان الغواصات النوويه
العالمون التحتيه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في
اسيا ويراهن بجديه على مواجهه تستمر
لسنوات طويله الولايات المتحده تبذل مساعي
لاخضاع دول اسيا لارادتها هذا يجب ان
يتوقف
سين من جانبها اعربت عن اعتراضها الشديد
على اتفاق اوكوس وقال المتحدث باسم
الوزاره ان الدول الثلاث تغاضت عن مخاوف
الصين وتعمل ضد الاتفاقيات الدوليه
واختارت الطريقه الخطا بحسب تعبيره
الصين تشدد على ان اتفاق اوكسو بين امريكا
واستراليا وبريطانيا سيقود نظام عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه ونعبر عن اعتراضنا
الشديد عليه لانه يبين ان هذه الدول
الثلاث تغاضت عن القلق الذي عبرنا عنه
واختارت الطريق الخطا نشر اسلحه تعتمد على
اليورانيوم في المحيط الهادئ ضد
الاتفاقيات الدوليه ليس في صالح المستوى
الدولي لذلك تعرض الصين بيع غواصات
النوويه الاستراليا هذه الدول الثلاث يجب
ان تتراجع عن الترتيبات التي تهدد دولا
اخرى ويجب عليها التخلي عن هذا السلوك
الذي يهدف لاحتواء الصين
بينما دفع وزير الدفاع الاسترالي عن
الاتفاقيه وقال انها ضروريه لمواجهه اكبر
حشد عسكريا تقليدي في المنطقه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
كان هناك جهد دبلوماسي ضخم مستمر منذ شهور
وزاد بشكل خاص خلال الاسبوع الماضي بيني
وبين وزير الخارجيه ورئيس الوزراء واجرينا
اكثر من 60 مكالمه مع القاده الاقليميين
والعالميين داخل المحيط الهادئ نشاهد
النظام العالمي القائمه على القواعد يتعرض
لضغط هائل في اوروبا الشرقيه وفي المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ ونحن نشهد اكبر حشد عسكري
تقليدي شاهدناه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وهذا يحدث داخل منطقتنا وعلينا
الرد على ذلك
الى الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
خلال تجمع حاسد لمؤيديه في ولايه ايوا
انهم لم يكن هناك وقت اكثر خط وره على
العالم مثل هذه الايام بعد دفع الرئيس جو
بايدن روسيا الى احضان الصين
عندما تكون طفلا يدرس التاريخ فان الشيء
الوحيد الذي بامكانك ان تتعلمه هو انه لا
يجب جمع روسيا والصين معا لتشكيل تحالف
لقد فعل بايدن ذلك لديهم تحالف كبير وجميل
الان وقد دفع روسيا الى احضان الصين
كشفت تايوان عن اول طائره مسيره متفجره من
صنعها تشبه طرازا امريكيا تستخدمه
اوكرانيا واشار المعهد الوطني للعلوم في
تايوان الى ان هذه الطائره صغيره بما يكفي
لحملها في حقيبه ظهر ويمكنها ان تحلق في
الجو لمده خمسه عشره دقيقه ولفت ولفت الى
ان تايوان تعمل ايضا على تطوير جيل جديد
من المسيرات الانتحاريه
تقدم وزير الامن البريطاني
بطلب الى المركز البريطاني للامن
السيبراني للنظر في مدى الحاجه الى حظر
تطبيق تيك توك الصيني من الهواتف الحكوميه
وداع الوزير البريطاني الى ضروره فهم
التهديدات التي يمثلها هذا التطبيق قبل
اتخاذ اي قرار بخصوص الموضوع ونفى ذات
المتحدث اتخاذ اي قرار بهذا الخصوص مؤكدا
ان الموضوع لا يزال قيد الدراسه من طرف
الجهات المختصه ولم يستبعد وزير الامن
البريطاني ان تحذوا بلاده حذو حكومات اخرى
في حظر التطبيق لكنه اكد ان اي خطوه ستتم
بعد الاطلاع على تقرير المركز الامن
السيبراني
سجلت الليره اللبنانيا انهيارا كبيرا
بعدما تخطى سعر الدولار حاجز مئه الف ليره
في السوق الموازيه هذا وبدات المصارف في
لبنان بتنفيذ اضراب مفتوح في مختلف
المناطق وذلك ردا على الاحكام القضائيه
التي صدرت في حقي بعض المصارف في الاونه
الاخيره وكان سعر الصرف الرسمي حدد او حدد
عند مستوى خمسه عشر الف ليره في مقابل
الدولار في شهر فبراير الماضي مقارنه مع
1507 ليرات سابقا
فقدت الاسهم الماليه العالميه 465 مليار
دولار من قيمتها السوقيه خلال ثلاثه ايام
مع خفض المستثمرين لانكشافهم على المصارف
عقب انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي وكانت البنوك
الامريكيه هي الاكثر تضررا بين الشركات
المدرجه
وفي جديد تطورات الازمه اكد رئيس
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي جيروم باول ان التعطر
المفاجئ لبنك سيليكون فالي يستدعي مراجعه
شامله وشفافه وسريعه واضاف في اول في اول
لقاء ان نائب رئيس مجلس اداره الاحتياطيه
الفيدرالي سيقود الاشراف على هذه المراجعه
وسيتم نشر النتائج في الاول من مايو
نشره الرابعه مستمره ونتابع
صندوق الاستثمارات السعوديه يعلن عن ضخ
خمسه مليارات ريال في شركات وطنيه
وتريليون ريال في مشاريع محليه جديده
اهلا بكم من جديد ننتقل بكم مباشره
مشاهدينا الى باكستان حيث نشاهد صور
مباشره لاعضاء من الشرطه تحاول اعتقال
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
هذه الصور ليست مباشره وانما وردتنا قبل
قليل لعناصر الشرطه ومحاوله لاعتقال
الرئيس السابق رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان بعد اصدار مذكره مذكره اعتقال بحقه
بالامس اذا هذه صور لمحاولات اعتقال
الرئيس الوزراء السابق الباكستاني عمران
خان في قضيه بيع هدايا من زعماء اجانب
وتجمع انصاره خارج المنزل وتستخدم الشرطه
كما يبدو الغاز المسيل للدموع وخراطيم
المياه لتفرقتهم وكانت قد توعد عمران خان
بتظاهرات احتجاجيه حاشده ضد قرار اعتقاله
وعلى ما يبدو الشرطه تحاول تفرقه هذه
الاحتجاجات وهذه التجمعات امام منزله
باستخدام الغاز المسيل للدموع وخرا المياه
كما نشاهد مشاهدينا عبر هذه الصور امامنا
على الشاشه
وخراطيم المياه لتفرقتهم هذه الدخاخين او
الدخان يتصاعد من امام منزل رئيس الوزراء
السابق الباكستاني عمران خان اثناء محاوله
الشرطه القاء القبض عليه وكان كما ذكرت
عمران خان توعد باحتجاجات حاشده وتجمعات
كبيره ومظاهرات ضد هذا القرار
ودعم القضاء بانه يحاول
منعه وانسحابه من
الانتخابات القادمه
وعوده الى سياق نشرتنا مشاهدينا انطلق
اليوم في الرياض اعمال منتدى صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه والقطاع الخاص واطلق
الصندوق السعودي عددا من المبادرات التي
تهدف الى دعمي وتمكين القطاع الخاص
والمساهمه في تحفيز نمو المحتوى المحلي
واعلن الصندوق السعودي عن اطلاق ثلاث
مبادرات رئيسيه من خلال المنتدى وتشمل
برنامج تنميه المحتوى المحلي والذي يهدف
لزياده مساهمه الصندوق والشركات التابعه
له في المحتوى المحلي الى 60% بنهايه عام
20 25 بالاضافه الى برنامج تطوير الموردين
ومنصه القطاع الخاص
ان ارحب بكم في خلال كلمته ضمن منتدى
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه والقطاع الخاص
اعلن محافظ صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
السعودي ياسر رميان اعلن عن استثمار خمسه
مليارات ريال في اربع شركات وطنيه وضغط
التريليون ريال في مشاريع جديده محليا
وقد استثمر الصندوق نحو 5 مليار ريال
سعودي في اربع شركات وطنيه رائده في قطاع
المقاولات شركه نسمه وشركائه من مقاولات
وشركه السيف وشركه البوان القابضه وشركه
المباني
عبر زياده راس مال الشركات بهدف بناء
كيانات متينه تواكب نهضه المملكه في قطاع
الترشيد والبناء
ويستهدف الصندوق من خلال استراتيجيه ضخ ما
يصل الى واحه تريليون ريال سعودي في
المشاريع الجديده محليا
مزيد
من مشاكل العبدلي
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه يعد المحرك
الفعال خلف تنوع الاقتصاد السعودي وعليه
قام صندوق مؤخرا بانشاء عدد من مشاريع
الكبرى لتحفيز الاقتصادي وبناء مجتمع حيوي
فعال مشاريع كان لها اثر كبير ومباشر على
المواطنين من ناحيه الخدمات والسكن
والترفيه وتوفير الوظائف وغيرها مثلا اذا
تناولنا مشاريع مدينه نيوم التي تمثل
المنظومه المستقبليه المتكامله للعيش
والعمل فستوفر حياه مدعومه بشكل كامل
بالطاقه النظيفه ومجتمعا يحافظ على البيئه
الطبيعيه واذا ما تحدثنا عن مشاريع
الصندوق التي فتحت باب السياحه في
السعوديه فهي كثيره كمشروع البحر الاحمر
الذي يعتبر وجهه سياحيه رائده ويمتد على
مساحه تزيد على 28 الف كيلو متر مربع
وتتمكن زواره مشاهدينا من الغوص في رابع
اكبر حيض مرجاني في العالم هذا المشروع
مشاهدينا سيوفر 7 الف فرصه عمل وعندما
تحدث عن اكبر وجهات العالميه التي تجمع
بين مجالات الترفيه والرياضه والثقافه
ياتي مشروع الجديه الذي سيحتوي على اكثر
من عشرين منطقه مختلفه كما سيضم اول منتزه
ترفيهي للالعاب المائيه في السعوديه
بالاضافه الى منتزه
الجديه الترفيهي ولاجل رفع مستوى جوده
الحياه في السعوديه ياتي دور شركه روشن
وهي شركه تطوير عقاريه مملوكه بالكامل
لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه تعمل مشاهدينا
روشين على بناء وتطوير احياء سكنيه
وعقارات تصاميمها مستلهمه من التراث في
السعودي الاصيل ولكونه يحتضن المعالم
الثقافيه والتراثيه للسعوديه اعلن الامير
محمد بن سلمان عن ضم مشروع الدرعيه كخامس
المشاريع الكبرى التابعه لصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه ليكون احد الوجهات
السياحيه الاكثر ردا وتميزا في العالم
مشروع مشاهدينا خدمات مميزه للمجتمع في
مجال الترفيه والتعليم والتسوق والتعامل
وكذلك الضيافه مساحات العمل والسكن ومن
المتوقع ان يحتضن المشروع مشاهدينا نحو
100 الف شخص واما مشروع المربع الجديد في
الرياض الذي يعتبر اكبر داون تاون حديث
عالميا سيوفر 300 واربعه وثلاثين الف فرصه
عمل واخر ما اعلن عنه صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه مشاهدينا هو تاسيس شركه طيران
الرياض الناقله الجوي الجديد او الناقل
الجوي الوطني الجديد للاسهام في تطوير
القطاع النقل الجوي وتعزيز موقع السعوديه
الاستراتيجي الذي يربط بين ثلاث من اهم من
اهم قارات العالم اسيا وافريقيا واوروبا
تهدف طيران الرياض مشاهدينا لاطلاق رحلات
تصل الى اكثر من 100 وجه 100 وجهه حول
العالم بحلول عام 20 30 واما عن عدد
الوظائف التي ستستحدثها الشركه فتصل الى
اكثر من 100 الف فرصه عمل
من منتدى صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
والقطاع الخاص ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نواف عزيز اهلا بك معنا النواف في نشره
الرابعه كيف تجري الامور
والمجريات هناك حيث انت
نعم فاطمه يشكل منتدى صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه السعودي والقطاع الخاص فرصه مهمه
للشركات المحليه الكبرى لبناء علاقات مع
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه وايضا الشركات
التابعه له هنا في هذا المنتدى معرض يوفر
اكثر من 50 جناحا تتواجد فيه الشركات
التابعه لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه
السعودي تتيح هذه الشركات الفرص والشراكات
للشركات المحليه في السعوديه وتتيح لها
ايضا الفرص للعمل في المشاريع الخاصه
بشركات الصندوق في مختلف مناطق السعوديه
هنا مبادره من الشركه السعوديه
الاستثماريه لاعاده التدوير مبادره جديده
وهي اجهزه ذاتيه لاعاده التدوير سوف توزع
هذه الاجهزه في مناطق السعوديه هو ستبدا
عمليه التوزي ع في مدينه الرياض 400 جهاز
ذاتي مثل هذا الجهاز سيتم توزيعها في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض تعيد التدوير
ذاتيا للعلب من خلال هذا الجهاز معي الان
رؤى العميم مدير التطوير الاعمال في
الشركه السعوديه الاستثماريه لاعاده
التدوير اهلا وسهلا رؤى في البدايه ما هي
هذه المبادره والهدف منها هي مبادرات
الاجهزه الذاتيه لاعاده تدوير قوارير
البلاستيك وعلب الالمنيوم الهدف منها ان
شاء الله توعيه المجتمع باهميه اعاده
التدوير من خلال الفرز من مصدر لتحقيق
اهداف السعوديه الخضراء ورؤيه 2030 تحويل
نسبه المرادم من 94% ان شاء الله الى سته
بالمئه من سته بالمئه الى اربعه وتسعين
بالمئه 94 الى 6% نعم
رؤى كيف يعمل هذا الجهاز الذاتي
البلاستيك
تتعرف عليها الجهاز
نضغط على انهاء ومن ثم ندخل
اذا نريد الحصول على النقاط نعم انها
المبادره اليه التوزيع في الرياض 400 جهاز
اين ستوزع ان شاء الله راح نوزعها في
المولات الجامعات المدارس الاماكن اللي هو
السوبر ماركت راح نوزعها بالاماكن اللي
تكون فيها هاي ترافيك كل الشكر لك رؤى اذا
فاطمه هذه المبادره التي يكشف عنها في
منتدى صندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعودي
ستبدا في الرياض وهي فكره جديده لتحقيق
عده اهداف اهداف السعوديه الخضراء
المحافظه على البيئه هنا ايضا الصندوق
الاستثمارات السعودي وقع اليوم عده
اتفاقيات من بينها اتفاقيه مع وزاره
الشؤون البلديه والقرويه والاسكان لبحث
مبادرات تطوير اساليب البناء الحديث
والتقنيات المستخدمه في البناء الحديث بما
يعود بالنفع على قطاع الاسكان وايضا قطاع
التشييد في السعوديه صندوق الاست ثمارات
السعودي قدم العديد من المبادرات منذ عام
2017 اسس واحد وسبعين شركه وايضا وفر نحو
500 الف وظيفه مباشره وغير مباشره في
السعوديه من خلال المشاريع والشركات
والعقود التي يعمل عليها منذ ذلك الوقت
شكرا لك من منتدى صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه والقطاع الخاص مراسله العربيه نواف
عزيز
تنطلق غدا في السعوديه اعمال مؤتمر القطاع
المالي في دورته الثانيه مستمرا ليومين
متتاليين ويستهدف المؤتمر السعودي استشراف
افاق الاستثمار والفرص الممكنه للمستثمرين
في القطاع وتوجهات الجهات التشريعيه فيما
يخص مستهدفات تطوير القطاع المالي اضافه
الى مناقشه مواضيع العملات المستقره
وتاثير التقنيات الماليه على القطاع
ينضموا الى رئيس اللجنه الاشترافيه لمؤتمر
القطاع المالي ومستشار وزير الماليه يعرب
ثنيان اهلا بك معنا استاذ يعرب في نشره
الرابعه اذا هذا المؤتمر في نسخته الثانيه
وصل الان الى مراحله النهائيه في
الترتيبات كيف تجري حتى الان هذه المرحله
شكرا جزيلا والحمد لله على قدم الوساق
اليوم احنا نتطلع نترقب الى الاطلاق غدا
باذن الله تسير ترتيبات بشكل ممتاز وفقا
للخط المرسومه والحمد لله وان شاء الله
بكره باذن الله تنطلق انطلاقا مميزه
وايجابيه باذن الله تعالى لمده يومين
بمشيئه الله طيب استاذ يعرب
اللقاء الاعلامي المصاحب لهذا المؤتمر
تطرق انه راح يكون في الكثير من
الاتفاقيات الكثير من
التفاهمات ستحصل مع على صعيدين المحلي
والدولي فبالتالي ما ابرز هذه الاتفاقيات
التي ستعقد وحجمها تحديدا
طبعا كما اعلنا بيكون عندنا اكثر من 60
اتفاقيه واعلان على مدار يومين باذن الله
طبعا العربيه معنا شريك نعتز فيه بشكل
كبير حتشهدوا هذا الاتفاقيات باي شكلي اذا
رجعنا الى اهداف المؤتمر
هي تنطلق يعني من اهداف مختلفه وبالتالي
كل الاتفاقيات والاعلانات بتكون على هذه
المحاور بمعنى اليوم احنا نعتقد في منصه
المؤتمر المؤتمر قطاع المالي هي منصه
دوليه في الواقع
ليست بعيده الاشياء المحلي لكن النقاش
بيكون دولي نشتكي ونتكلم عن جميع الهموم
ونتطلع الى الفرص وبالتالي اليوم احد اهم
المحاور اللي نبدا فيه باذن الله غدا
صباحا هو محور الفرص والتحديات اللي
موجوده في اقصاد العالم اليوم مثل ما
تعرفين احنا نشوف في تحديات كبيره في حاله
عدم اليقين اسباب جيوسياسيه غيرت كثير من
سلاسل الامداد
كذلك تحديات على يعني على مستوى
التطلعات الاقتصاديه نشوف كثير من تدبذبات
معدلات النمو ارتفاع كبير بمعدلات التضخم
خلقت حاله بالقلق حاله من عدم الوضوح
اليوم جميع الصناع القرار سواء كان في
الجانب
التشريعي او في الجانب بيئه الاعمال
الاقتصاديه او في القطاع المالي بيناقشون
هذه التحديات وبالتالي بيطلعون بافكار
جديده لمقابلتها ايضا المؤسسات الماليه
وهي المكون الرئيسي لقطاع المالي ينبغي
عليه ايضا تكون مرنه
وبالتالي تتوائم وتواكب هذا التحديات
الموجوده كذلك ليس ليس بمعزل في هذا في
هذا اللقاء عن الاستثمار من اجل الغد وين
بنركز ما هي المخرجات الرئيسيه اللي اليوم
اذا خرجنا من هذه التحديات راح نتوجهلها
وبالتالي نستفيد من فرص اليوم عندنا
التقنيه والرقم غيرت كثير من اللاند سكيب
الخاص في القطاع المالي وكذلك في في جانب
قطاع الاعمال وبالتالي جميع الاتفاقيات
اللي تحدثنا عنها ستكون من هذه المخرجات
من هذه المكونات الرئيسيه للمؤتمر جيد طيب
استاذ يعرب قيمه هذه الاتفاقيات هل من رقم
ربما معلن بما انها يعني اتفاقيات كثيره
ليست بالقليله
صحيح لكن
وبعد غد وافضل ان تكون احد المفاجات
الجيده لهذا المؤتمر
وقد يكون هذا الموضوع الخاص بالقيمه مهم
لكن ايضا المحتوى اهم اليوم احنا نود ان
نتشكل بشكل جيد عالميا ونمكن من خلال هذه
المنصه لحلول وافكار كبيره جدا راح تحدث
في المستقبل كما كان الحال في النسخه
السابقه
مع قربي شهر رمضان تزايدت اعداد المعتمرين
ما دفع السلطات في مكه لمضاعفه الفرق
الرقابيه الميدانيه هذا هو سجلت منافذ
الدخول في مكه قرابه سبعه ملايين معتمر من
خارج السعوديه منذ بدء موسم العمره كما
باشرت الجهات الرقابيه والخدميه اعمالها
في مكه المكرمه حيث تعمل على تنظيم عمليه
الاستقبال ومغادرات الحافلات من المدينه
المنوره الى مكه المكرمه او جده عبر مطار
الملك عبد العزيز في حين تعملوا رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين على تقديم خدماتها في اروقه
الحرم من خلال الترجمه وعمليات التعقيم
التي تتم بشكل يومي
من مكه للمكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي اهلا بك معنا سلطان انقل لنا
الصوره لديك وابرز الاستعدادات التي تقوم
بها السلطات في مكه
اهلا بك فاطمه اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل تشهد المنافذ البريه
والجويه السعوديه اقبال كبير من قبل
المعتمرين اما الخارج وكذلك حتى من
المعتمرين من الداخل الذين ياتون او
يتوافدون الى الحرم المكي بشكل كبير جدا
وملحوظ قبيل بدء شهر رمضان اتسجلت الجهات
الحكوميه العامله في قطاع العمره اكثر من
سبعه ملايين معتمر منذ بدء الموسم وهذا
الرقم يتزايد بشكل يومي لذلك عملت معها
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين وكافه القطاعات
الخدميه العامله هنا ممثله في الجهات
الامنيه وغيرها بتكثيف خدماتها والعمل على
تطبيق خطه رمضان مع بدايه واحد رمضان لذلك
نشاهد الان قبل قبل بدء موسم رمضان هنالك
اعداد كبيره من القطاعات الخدميه العامله
في المسجد الحرام كذلك نتحدث على مراكز
استقبال المعتمرين تم تفعيلها استعدادا
لدخول شهر رمضان ما المعتاد انه في كل
موسم بدا رمضان من كل عام تشهد الحرم
المكي اعداد كبيره جدا لذلك بدات عمليات
الحجوزات للعمره في شهر رمضان حجوزات
كبيره امتلات بشكل كامل تحديدا نتحدث على
منذ بدء شهر رمضان وحتى المنتصف شهر رمضان
امتلات الحجوزات وكذلك يتم تحديثها بشكل
يومي وفتح الحجوزات نتحدث على صحن المطاف
تحديدا يتواجد به حاليا تحدث على استيعاب
107 الاف
معتمر في الساعه الواحده خلال عبر الصحن
عبر الدوري الارضي والادوار الاولى
والثانيه والثاني اذا كذلك فتح كامل
التوسيعات للتعامل والساحات لاستقبال اكبر
عدد ممكن من المعتمرين والمصلين قبل بدا
موسم رمضان لذلك ايضا نشاهد نمو كبير
وحركه كبيره للحافلات مكه التي تم تخصيصها
العام الماضي وبدات بشكل كبير في نقل
المعتمرين المصلين من والى الحرم المكي
عبر مسارات خاصه القطاعات العامله في
الحرم المكي وكذلك القطاعات الخدميه
والامنيه لتنظيم عمليات
دخول وخروج المعتمرين في شهر شعبان ايضا
يتم هذه الفتره دخول كافه المعتمرين وكافه
المصلين بدون اي حجوزات سوف تبدا عمليه
الحجوزات خلال شهر رمضان لضبط عمليه دخول
وخروج المعتمرين بكل يسر وسهوله نعم شكرا
لك من مكه المكرمه مراسل العربيه سلطان
السلمي على كل هذه المعلومات
الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها رمضان في
السعوديه على موعد مع موجات امطار اعلى من
معدلها الطبيعي
روسيا تستعد لمضاعفه انتاج الصواريخ عاليه
الدقه وتؤكد ان اهدافها لن تتحقق في
اوكرانيا الا بالقوه
مع قرب شهر رمضان مكه المكرمه تضاعف الفرق
الرقابيه وتسجل دخول سبعه ملايين معتمر من
خارج السعوديه
لاول مره في السعوديه البدء بتجربه تقنيه
جديده لتبريد الطرق تهدف لتخفيف حراره
الاحياء السكنيه
وروشن تطلق اول مشاريعها في المنطقه
الشرقيه
سيوفر في مدينه الهفوف اكثر من 18,000
وحده سكنيه
احييكم من جديد ولاول مره في السعوديه
كشفت الهيئته العامه للطرق عن البدء
باجراء تجربه تقنيه جديده لتبريد الطرق في
البلاد فما هي هذه التجربه وكيف تعمل
في ظل امتصاص الطرق لدرجات الحراره
المرتفعه خلال الصيف لتصل احيانا الى
سبعين درجه مئويه اطلقت الهيئه العامه
للطرق تجربه ما يعرف بالارتفه البارده وهي
عباره عن عده مواد محليه الصنع لها القدره
على امتصاص كميات اقل من الاشعه الشمسيه
وقدرتها على عكس الاشعه ومن ثم تكون درجه
حراره سطحها اقل من الارصفه التقليديه
وتناسب هذه الماده طرق المحيطه بالمناطق
السكنيه وتهدف الى خفض درجه الحراره في
الاحياء والمناطق السكنيه وتقليل الطاقه
المستخدمه في تبريد المباني وبالاضافه الى
تقليل اثار تغير المناخ وايضا تساهم في
توفير بيئه اكثر راحه في مناطق الانتظار
والمناطق التي يتجمع فيها الناس
الى العلا حيث انطلقت اليوم منافسات
النسخه الاولى من كاس العلا للهجن والذي
يعد حدثا استثنائيا يهدف الى تطوير رياضه
الهجن كما يسعى المتنافسون من السعوديه
ودول الخليج الى الفوز باكبر حصه من مجموع
جوائز كاس العلا للهجره والتي تمثل اعلى
الجوائز الماليه في العالم للشوط الواحد
وتقام المنافسات على مدار اربعه ايام في
ميدان العلا للهجن والتي تبلغ مساحته نحو
20 الف كيلو مترا مربعا
في السعوديه اطلقت مجموعه روشن مشروع
الفلوه والذي ياتي رابع مجتمع سكني تطوره
المجموعه التابعه الى صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه وبمساحه تزيد عن
10.8 مليون متر مربع وعلى بعد سبعه كيلو
مترات من وسط مدينه الهفوف المشروع
العقاري السعودي الاول في المنطقه الشرقيه
سيضم اكثر من 18 الف وحده سكنيه بطاقه
استيعابيه تصل الى اكثر من 100 الف نسمه
ويساهم مشروع الفلوه في تقليل تكاليف
استهلاك الطاقه بنسبه 18% ويحقق ايضا مبدا
الاستدامه في التصميم والبناء كما يعمل
كذلك على انشاء مرافق حضاريه ضمن بيئه
صحيه وطبيعيه مشاريعها السكنيه
في الاثناء وقعت الهيئه الملكيه في الجبيل
شرق السعوديه عددا من الاتفاقيات والعقود
الاستثماريه بقيمه 8 مليارات ريال كما
اتفقت الهيئه مع المركز الوطني للرقابه
على الالتزام البيئي لانشاء مقر وباستثمار
يقدر ب 270 مليون ريال بالاضافه الى توفير
وظائف للسعوديين والسعوديات في جهات
مختلفه
وتنوعات الاتفاقيات ما بين استثمارات
صناعيه وخدمات تجاريه من بينها انشاء
مدينه طبيه حيث تهدف الاتفاقيات الجديده
لتوفير كافه الخدمات لسكان المدينه
والارتقاء بجوده الحياه فيها
انضموا الينا الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه
الملكيه في الجبال الدكتور احمد ال حسين
اهلا بك معنا دكتور في نشره الرابعه دكتور
يعني عقود استثماريه بقيمه ثمانيه مليارات
في الجبيل ماذا تحتاج الجبيل من هذه
المشاريع وماليه توزيعها تحديدا
اولا نرحب بك اخت فاطمه بجميع الاخوان
المشاهدين واشكر لقناه العربيه حرصها على
تغطيه الفعاليات المختلفه والاحداث في
المدينه
وكما ذكرتي هنالك مجموعه من الاتفاقيات
الاستثماريه المتنوعه ما بين صناعيه
وتجاريه
والتي يعني لم تاتي للمدينه الا بسبب
جاهزيه وجاذبيه المدينه للاستثمار فيها
فيما يتعلق بالتصنيف يعني احنا نصنفها الى
تجاري والصناعي ما يتعلق بالصناعي نستطيع
ان نقول انها الاستثمارات التي
نحرص فيها على رفع مستوى جوده الحياه
واما الصناعيه
فالمستهدف فيها يكون من خلال النموذج
الصناعي الذي يمتد او ياتي من خلال الخطه
الشامله للمدينه
والتي ايضا تتوائم مع الاستراتيجيه
الصناعيه وكذلك هنالك ايضا الجانب السكني
وهو الخاص بتوفير الوحدات السكنيه لموظفي
الشركات
طيب دكتور يعني كيف تسهم هذه المشاريع
تحديدا في تحسين جوده الحياه لانه ربما
هذه احد اهداف هذه المشاريع اليس كذلك
نعم صحيح هي هي لا شك من مستهدفات رفع
جوده الحياه وكذلك
النمو الصناعي المستهدف في المدينه لا شك
انها هنالك مجموعه من العوامل او الفوائد
التي سنجنيها من خلال تلك الاستثمارات
والتي يعني تاتي او ياتي في طليعتها
الوظائف النوعيه وكذلك رفع مستوى او يعني
المنتج المحتوى المحلي وكذلك
قيمه
تجميع الاقتصاد كذلك والمساهمه بزياده
الايرادات الغير نفطيه بالاضافه الى تعزيز
الاستدامه والتكامل الصناعي والتجاري ودعم
سلاسل القيمه الخاصه بالامداد وكذلك
يعني كما ذكرت سابقا الفرص النوعيه لتلك
المشاريع
اود ان اسالك ربما سؤالي الاخير عن هل من
مدى زمنيه ربما مطروحه الى متى سيجني اهل
الجبال ثمار هذه المشاريع
الحقيقه تتفاوت الفترات الزمنيه ولكن يعني
في
مجملها يعني
الصناعات
المشاريع الصناعيه قد تاخذ يعني بعض الوقت
وكذلك المشاريب الكبيره التجاريه قد تاخذ
بعض الوقت وهناك مجموعه يعني منها في
المدينه الحمد لله تم بشكل سريع مثل يعني
بعض المشاريع التجاريه ذموذ على سبيل
المثال وهنالك ايضا مشاريع على وشك
اطلاقها في جانب التجاري مثل مشروع مجمع
الغانم وسيبدا العمل ان شاء الله ايضا على
مجمع العثيم
ما يتعلق بالجانب الصناعي كما ذكرت قد
تاخذ يعني بعض الوقت تبعا للدراسات وما
يلزم من الاعداد الخاص بذلك واضح وطبعا
مهما اخذت
من واقنه لك الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه
الملكيه في الجبيل دكتور احمد الحسين
بمناسبه مرور مئه عام على الرحله
التاريخيه للملك فيصل الى فرنسا تستضيف
العاصمه باريس في مقر اليونسكو لغايه
الرابع والعشرين من مارس معرض الفيصل
مئه عام واكثر مرت على الرحله التاريخيه
للملك فيصل بن عبد العزيز الى اوروبا على
وقع هذه الذكرى شهدت العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس وتحديدا مقر اليونسكو تدشين معرض
الفيصل حياه في القرن العشرين لتكون
المحطه الثانيه للمعرض بعد لندن
نعرض هذا يلقي نظره على حياه مليئه
بالاحداث خاصه في القرن الميلادي الماضي
لانه الملك فيصل الله يرحمه عاصر السلام
والحرب لانها تمت في في خضم مؤتمر للسلام
العالمي بعد انقضاء الحرب العالميه الاولى
فالاهميه تقع في ذلك مساهمته في جعل
الاحداث تسير ليس فقط في منطقتنا في
العالم العربي ولكن في بقيه انحاء العالم
يضم المعرض سبعه اقسام فيها شرح مفصل عن
الرحله بالاضافه الى مجموعات من مقتنيات
الملك فيصل الخاصه وبرقياته وصوره
الفوتوغرافيه التي توثق تاريخ الزياره فان
المعرض يعني يحكي قصه الملك فيصل بشكل عام
وبالاخص رحلته التاريخيه التي اداها عندما
كان شابا نافعا عام 1919 بعد الحرب
العالميه
وكيف تعرض لتجارب مختلفه في رحلته هذه
ايضا بعض المقتنيات الشخصيه للملك فيصل
وايضا جزء من كسوه الكعبه التي صنعت في
عهد الملك فيصل كل هذه الامور اكيد تعكس
الرحله المتميزه للملك فيصل طيب الله ثراه
ولتفاعل مجتمع الدولي ايضا معه تعاون
مستمر توثقه المعارض والمناسبات الثقافيه
بين السعوديه واليونسكو احدثها هذا المعرض
الذي يستمر حتى الرابع والعشرين من مارس
الجاري
هنا في اروقه مقر اليونسكو في باريس
يستحضر هذا المعرض ذكرى مرور 100 عام على
جوله الملك فيصل التاريخيه في اوروبا
والتي كان لها دور كبير في بناء وترسيخ
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والغرب والتي استمرت حتى يومنا
هذا زينه عدي العربيه باريس
بعد موجتي هطول الامطار الغزيره في
السعوديه توقع المركز الوطني للارصاد
ارتفاعا وتيره هطول الامطار على نحو
اعلامنا المعدل الطبيعي كما توقعت ايضا
ارتفاع درجات الحراره على معظم مناطق
السعوديه خلال شهر رمضان المقبل وبمقدار
يصل الى 1.5 درجه خلال شهر مارس مع
احتماليه حدوث موجات حراريه خاصه على
مناطق شمال شرقي السعوديه
خلال هذه الايام ينتشر الربيع وتخرج
الحشرات والزواحف التفاصيل مع تقويم او
خالد ازعاج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
البرد له بدايه وشده ونهايه فبدايته مع
موسم الصفري في اول شهر اكتوبر وشدته مع
موسم اليزيري في اول يناير ونهايته مع
نهايه برد العجوز في اخر شهر مارس ونحن
الان نعيش في موسم برد بياع الخبل عباته
وهو البرد الذي يلسعنا على حين غفله من
امرنا ولهذا يسمى بل عقرب لا ادبر الدنيا
والحظ ما طاب الناس لا من طحت ما يرحمونك
لا تامن العقرب ولا تامن الداب اسهم واحد
لا رقى
في متونك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وخلال هذه الايام ينتشر الربيع بجميع
انواعه وتخرج الحشرات والزواحف والهواء
مسامه العقارب والثعابين من مخابئها
ويلسعنا النهار بشمسه ويسعنا الليل ببرده
ويلسعنا المناخ بتقلباته الجويه ولهذا
تنتشر عندنا الامراض الموسميه وهذه هي
تكاليف الحياه سئمت تكاليف الحياه ومن يعش
ثمانين حولا لا ابا لك ياسامي رايت
المنايا خبط عشواء من تصب تمجه ومن تخطئ
يعمر
فيا حرامي
[موسيقى]
نتابع معكم مشاهدينا صور من العلا وانطلاق
منافسات النسخه الاولى من كاس العلا للهجن
والذي يعد حدثا استثنائيا طبعا يهدف
لتطوير رياضه الهجن وتقام هذه المنافسات
على مدار اربعه ايام في العلا للهجن والتي
تبلغ مساحه نحو 20,000 كيلومتر مربع في
الختام نذكر بالعناوين
روسيا تستعد لمضاعفه انتاج الصواريخ عاليه
الدقه وتؤكد ان اهدافها لن تتحقق في
اوكرانيا الا بالقوه
مع قرب شهر رمضان مكه المكرمه تضاعف الفرق
الرقابيه وتسجل دخول سبعه ملايين معتمر من
خارج السعوديه
لاول مره في المملكه البدء بتجربه تقنيه
جديده لتبريد الطرق تهدفه لتخفيف حراره
الاحياء السكنيه
وروشن تطلق اول مشاريعها في المنطقه
الشرقيه سيوفر في مدينه الهفوف اكثر من 18
الف وحده سكنيه في امان الله
[موسيقى]